hi everyone I'm Gus and I want you all
to know your Maps might be lying to you
so normally I like to set the stage but
in order to keep it in theme I'm going
to map the stage instead some maps are
bad and I want to walk through some of
the reasons on why that can be let's
start with this world map which while
it's meant to be decorative it's got
some pretty glaring issues Australia
Iceland and Hawaii are all missing along
with a bunch of other weird mistakes
like the Suez Canal not existing if we
take a look at this map of the United
States it also has a few issues Cape cot
is missing Long Island seems to be
floating away from New York State the
Upper Peninsula of Michigan is missing
entirely there's something weird going
on in the DC Capital Region and the
Alaskan uan islands and the Florida keys
are both missing now if we take a look
at New Zealand a country that's pretty
well known for being left off of world
maps and we go to their government's
website it turns out that they also left
themselves off the map but this one's
actually on purpose to make a joke about
it because this is from the 404 page not
found and so it would be 404 New Zealand
not found not only are some maps bad but
even when they're good getting the
borders just right can be pretty tricky
too that's because the borders can
depend on where you are who you ask and
even if you were to ask the same person
it could depend on when you ask them if
for example we were to ask data Hub how
much of Miami is in the United States
you might be a little surprised when
they say not all of Miami is in the
United
States and it looks like that's mostly
just due to some low polygon resolution
or maybe we could ask the World Bank
where the border between Peru and
Ecuador is and in this case that Gray
Line you see is the true border and the
blue line is what the World Bank thinks
the border is and so it looks like maybe
the Border has been shifted to the left
a bit and it's got a lower resolution
but you're probably thinking the World
Bank seems like a pretty important
institution why can't they get their
borders right
if we hold on to that question for a
minute and hope that it's some sort of
fluke and try and look at let's say
Natural Earth instead we can see that
Roosevelt Island is outside the United
States it turns out data Hub actually
has this problem too where it looks like
some extra polygons that could surround
the island aren't included and it also
raises the question how far up a river
do you go when trying to map out a
country's borders but by now you're
probably thinking well even though
everyone else is confused about where
the borders are surely the US Department
of State knows where the borders are
they do their best but they're not
perfect like with this border between
Egypt and Sudan where you don't have two
extra small countries tucked in there
but to be fair to the Department of
State this is a disputed border so can
be helpful to know that both versions of
the Border exist if we move South a
little and look at the border between
Sudan and arria it looks like the
Department of State maybe has some extra
resolution that the truth map doesn't
have and it looks like it's been shifted
maybe up and to the left just the
tiniest bit okay well what if we check
an easy one like the Vatican I mean
they've got walls the walls are straight
lines and they're hundreds of years old
and we're built in around 850 ad so that
should be more than enough time to to
really go in and make sure you're
getting the borders right they actually
did a pretty good job here and while
that border isn't quite perfect and does
go down the middle of a road for a
little bit it's still far better than
the other two examples we've seen so far
at this point you might be thinking so
what if the Department of State gets a
few International borders a little bit
wrong because surely the US Department
of State knows where the United States
borders are they don't this is the
Border between Mexico and Arizona with
Mexico on the left and Arizona on the
right but to their credit they did get
the 49th parallel with Canada right
probably because it's a relatively
straight
line on paper these may seem like some
relatively minor problems but in reality
they can stir up a bit of trouble you
could have property disputes and this is
exactly why people get surveys they want
to know where they borders are it could
be problems with water rights or border
security because if you've got border
patrols you want to make sure they're
patrolling on the right side of the
Border if you even know where your
border is so what's going wrong with all
these Maps why are all of the borders in
the wrong spot and the truth is I
haven't been entirely truthful with you
guys I've been comparing everything to
the open street map base maps and what
made those Maps the true map and who
made me the Orbiter of what is and isn't
the true map and I also didn't check my
projections while I did check my
coordinate reference systems and I'll
get into what those are more in just a
minute all that to say that if I were to
take the open street map borders and
plot it against the open street map base
map then sure enough everything lines up
and it all looks great when we go back
and compare with the Department of state
borders I do need to give them some
credit because this particular stretch
of border is complicated because the
original treaty that defined this border
was based on the path of the river but
over time the river has shifted so the
question becomes is the modern-day
border Where the River used to be when
the treaty was signed or is it where the
river is now and constantly changing
besides fun keyboarders you could also
have a few other common problems with
your Maps like I mentioned before you
could have a problem with your
projection which is how you're choosing
to represent a 3D spherical Planet sorry
flat earthers on a 2d map or it could be
a problem with your coordinate reference
system which is how you choose to plot
the points on that now 2D projection of
the
planet you could also have data problems
which could be some incomplete data or
you could have extra data Maybe in the
form of extra features or all versions
of it disputed border like we saw with
Egypt and Sudan you could also have
incorrect or out ofd data some file type
or data type mismatches you could have a
different data resolution between two
different data sets or you could even
have fake data that map makers put in
there so that if someone tries to steal
their Maps they can point at this fake
location in court and say look this
isn't a real place this person stole my
map and you can tell because they have
the same fake place too I actually came
across a really great example of some
incorrect data the other night when
Nicole and I were walking to dinner and
we'd gotten separated from the group and
so we wanted to know where in the world
is Travis noji for those of you that
don't know Travis is a cooworker of ours
at Lander and while we were walking
Nicole realized that she actually has
Travis in find my friends on her phone
and so she pulled open the app she was
really excited to see that Travis was
sitting in the middle of the pomac river
well we wouldn't have been too surprised
if Travis had made the decision to go
for a sudden evening swim it didn't seem
quite right and we did eventually find
him next to the Georgetown University
sign to better illustrate how far off
Travis's phone's location was from
reality I've marked his actual location
with a red star on the map okay yeah
Maps can have a lot of problems but now
what what can I actually do about it
just like I found my source of Truth
with the open street map base Maps you
also need to find your source of Truth
every map starts with a base map and
every base map has four main features it
has a function which could be street map
satellite view could be a hybrid Street
Satellite
topographic it has a style which could
be the if it's full color maybe it's
grayscale dark map or it might have
labels or it could not have labels
you'll also have different data sources
which could be open street map the
government mapbox Overture maps and many
more and you lastly you'll have your
coordinate reference system which for
frequently is wgs84 but there are tons
of other reference systems out there as
well when choosing your base map it's
important to go back and consider those
four features so with your function what
is it you're trying to show with your
style is there a certain style that
helps communicate the point you're
trying to make or is there a certain way
that you want to display your data to
make a specific impact when thinking
about your data sources where does your
data come from do that does that data
provider have a base map of their own
that you can use and with the coordinate
reference system it's really important
to make sure that you're matching your
system to the reference system used by
your data provider when it comes to
adding data there's a lot of other
things to consider as well your data
layers could be any data of your own
maybe it's data you've collected or
maybe it could be data that you've
gotten from some other provider like
border
roads weather patterns it could be the
migratory patterns of Canada geese or
the locations of working McDonald's ice
screen machines in the Washington DC
area your data could also come in a few
different formats you can have raster
layers which are tiled images like
satellite view or weather radar and
these have a specific resolution and
that's why frequently maps have to
reload when you zoom in you could also
have Vector layers or are lines and
polygons and sometimes images and these
are usually used to communicate Borders
or paths and then you could also have UI
layers like markers popups or tool tips
some extra way to communicate
information to a user and then a bunch
more other kinds of data layers as well
but Gus you might be thinking this is
complicated and I really don't
care yeah that hurts but fair enough you
don't always need Super accurate
locations like you don't need to know
where in the McDonald's the ice cream
machine is located because chances are
they're not going to let you behind the
counter anyways and you really just need
to know where the McDonald's itself is
you could also be looking for population
centers in cities which really only
needs to come down to around a block or
so radius before anything more specific
just wouldn't be that helpful you could
also be using using a map as a
visualization where the data itself is
what matters like a chloropleth which
are those colorful polygon maps that are
frequently used to illustrate voting as
well as visualizations of a Region's
water sheds or maybe something else it
could really be any situation where
you're trying to convey some other data
using the map as a platform the
important thing is just be consistent
make sure you know what projection
you're using same goes for your
coordinate reference system and make
sure both of those match your data
sources and your base map sources
because once everything's on the same
field your Borders or whatever data
you're trying to plot will me be in a
much better spot than it would be
otherwise while some maps might be bad
all maps are lying to you when you're
making your own do you know what you're
sacrificing to communicate your message
and when you're looking at someone
else's do you know and are you able to
tell what they've sacrificed to be able
to communicate theirs and that my
friends is how your Maps might be lying
to
you